remember purpose is foundational it's
not like I want to be the best or I want
to be number one or I want to you know
that those things are good and important
the goals are valid and valuable but
that's not the reason you get out of bed
in the morning you know the reason your
spouse loves you is not because you're
the top salesperson you know
um you know the reason you're the reason
your your friends rely on you is not
because of your knowledge of the product
you know purpose is foundational and it
absolutely applies at work because who
you are at home and who you are at work
should be consistent that's what we mean
by authenticity if you're different in
both of these places than in one of
those two places you're lying we want to
know who you are and show up as yourself
now that doesn't mean we can't be
professional at work those two are uh
you know you can still be professional
and be yourself
um and fundamentally when when we are
ourselves we connect better
whether it's teammates or people or
customers we connect People Like Us who
share our values and and see the world
the way we see it you know we can't get
along with everybody and a great
salesperson knows when there's not a
good personality connection that they'll
actually say to somebody else you take
this one you know you can close this
deal I I won't be able to or you can get
a better deal and it's understanding
that when we show up as our true selves
we're much better able to truly connect
with people uh and Inspire them to do
the same by the way remember a hundred
percent of customers are people
and 100 of employees are people and 100
of investors are people and
fundamentally business as a human is a
human industry if you don't understand
people you don't understand business and
we succeed as people when we work
together we are social animals who need
each other we need each other in hard
times we need each other in good times
and so the better we Foster
relationships internally and externally
this is the recipe for successful change
and quite frankly success in anything we
do